in the previous video we looked at how
angles are measured using degrees this
angle would measure around 30 degrees a
right angle would measure 90 degrees a
straight line 180 degrees and one
complete rotation 360 degrees do you
know why 360 degrees it's somewhat
arbitrary and had something to do with
the base 60 number system do we have
some other way in which we can measure
angles such that it makes a little more
sense yes that brings us to the concept
of radians and trust me not many people
understand what radians mean most people
know how to convert from degrees to
radians and vice versa but it ends there
to understand what radians mean let's
draw a circle let point O be its center
and length RP its radius now let me take
this length R and place it here at this
point now all I do is push it onto the
circumference of the circle the length
of this red part is still R it has just
become curved and that's all the curved
length R starts from here and ends here
now from the center of the circle we
draw another radius that joins the other
endpoint of the red curve this length
will also be R as it's the radius let's
analyze the figure we have an arc of
length equal to the radius of the circle
and two radii joining the center and the
endpoints of that arc remember the
length of the arc is equal to the radius
of the circle this angle formed here is
one Radian that's the concept of radians
actually there's radius everywhere
around this angle R R and R and that's
probably why they call it radians
according to various scientists and
mathematicians this is a more logical
way to measure angles it's because we're
measuring the angle in relation to the
radius of the circle but how are radians
related to degrees what was this angle
be equal to integral if you understood
the concept of radians well then
understanding the conversion between
degrees and radians would be a walk in
the park what is the circumference of a
circle
it's 2 pi R where R is the radius of the
circle we are talking about the
circumference which is the entire
boundary of the circle now listen to the
next question well how many such arcs
would you need to cover the entire
boundary of the circle let me repeat the
question how many such arcs of length R
would you need to cover the
circumference of the circle pause the
video and see if you can work through
this on your own
the length of the arc is R and the
circumference is 2 PI R yes 2 pi r it
means we would need 2 pi such arcs to
cover the circumference 2 pi arcs what
does that mean as pi is approximately
3.14 we would need 6.28 arcs to cover
the circumference how would it look this
is one arc 2 3 4 5 6 and a little part
left for 0.28 arc or 28% of an arc so we
need 2 pi arcs to cover the entire
circumference and what does each hour
correspond to at the center we have seen
that one arc corresponds to one Radian
at the center it implies that to
complete one full rotation we would need
two pi radians and it tells us something
more - if we rotate one arm completely
then two pi radians will be covered at
the center but wait hold on
we also know that one full rotation
equals 360 degrees yes one full rotation
equals 360 degrees as both equal one
full rotation these two will be equal to
pi radians will equal 360 degrees that's
the relation between degrees and radians
this is what we have been working
towards in this video if we understand
this we can easily derive the rest this
is one full rotation then how many
radians will 180 degrees be equal to if
we divide this equation by 2 we get pi
radians equal to 180 degrees
and 180 degrees is half circle or a
straight line and what about a right
angle if we divide this equation by two
we get PI over 2 radians equal to 90
degrees so a right angle is equivalent
to PI by 2 radians these three relations
are most important when it comes to
conversion between degrees and radians
and we don't really need to remember all
three knowing just one is enough and we
can derive the rest and now we come to
the last and the most important point of
this video what does one Radian equal to
in degrees if we divide the first
equation by 2 pi we get one Radian as
360 over 2 pi degrees substituting the
value of pi as 3.14 we get the
approximate value of one Radian as
fifty-seven point two nine five eight
degrees that's the degree measure of one
Radian if we have an angle like this
which measures one Radian it will equal
fifty-seven point two nine five eight
degrees